[müzik]
Selamlar gençler. Ben Sercanız. Uzun bir
aradan sonra tekrardan merhabalar. Koca
bir yaz saatini bitirdik. Ben de
bayağıdır video çekmiyordum. Sizleri de
çok özledim. Yeni bir videoyla
sizlerleyim. Bu videomuzda tabii ki 9.
sınıf İngilizce 1inci temamız School
Life ünitesinin konu anlatımını
yapacağım. Geçen sene yapmıştım. Farklı
kaynaklardan yapmıştım. Bu sene farklı
bir kaynaktan yapacağım ve güncel bir
süre elinizde kaynak olsun ki 1ci
üniteyi rahatlıkla halledin. Çünkü 1ci
ünite önemli. Neden önemli? Çünkü
yazılılarınızın özellikle birinci yazılı
çoğunluğu bu üniteden gelecek gençler. O
yüzden önemli. Peki hocam bu ne derseniz
ben küçük bir kaza geçirdim gençler.
Maalesef tendonlarımda bir kopma durumu
söz konusu. O yüzden de sakatım. Boydan
boya böyle alçıdayım gençler. Geçmiş
olsunlarınızı almak istiyorum
yorumlarda. benim için dua edin. Kısa
zamanda iyileşmek istiyorum. Çünkü çok
zor böyle sakatlık. Allah kimseyi bu
durumlara düşürmesin. Sakatlığı bir
kenara bırakalım. Nasıl geçti yaz
tatiliniz? Bunlardan bir bahsedin.
Heyecan var mı gençler? Tamamen yeni bir
ortam, yeni arkadaşlıklar. 9.
sınıfsınız, lise 1'siniz gençler.
Hayırlı uğurlu olsun. Umarım harika bir
seneyi hep beraber geçiririz. İngilizce
de takip edin ki gençler bir eksiğiniz
kalmasın. Mutlaka kanala abone olun
aşağıdan ve videoya like atıp bana
destek olmayı da unutmayın lütfen. Daha
fazla gevzelik yapmayalım. Hadi hemen
bence konu anlatımımıza geçelim. Evet
gençler 1inci ünitemiz yani birinci
temamız School Life okul hayatı. Okul
hayatını şöyle bütün detaylarıyla
anlatmaya çalışacağım. Milli Eğitimin
kitabının biraz sıkıcı olduğunu
biliyorum. Gerçekten çok uzun metinler
var ve harbiden hem öğretmen hem de
sizler için zor olabiliyor. O yüzden
buradan biraz daha kolay olacak. Bunu,
bu dersi ben gençler More and More
Students Book 9'dan anlatıyorum
arkadaşlar. Yani 9. sınıf ders
kitabından More and More'dan
anlatıyorum. Gerçekten çok güzel
yapmışlar. Çok fazla detağı boğmadan,
gayet eğlenceli alıştırmalarıyla beraber
yapmışlar. Ben de alıştırmalar üzerinden
size bu konuyu anlatmaya çalışacağım.
Umarım sıkılmadan izleyebilirsiniz.
Belki like atmayı unutmuşsunuzdur.
Tekrar bir hatırlatayım. Like atmayı
unutmayın lütfen. Öncelikle gençler
burada önemli kelimeler var. Bakın
kelime listelerimiz var. Buradaki
kelimeleri ben tek size bahsetmeyeceğim
ama liste halinde görebiliyorsunuz.
İsterseniz ekran resmini alın,
isterseniz açın bir kitaba, deftere
yazın. Ama mutlaka bu kelimeleri şöyle
bir göz ucuyla bakın, kontrol edin. Kaç
tanesini zaten biliyorsunuz? Kaç
tanesini ezberlemek ihtiyacını
duyuyorsunuz. Bunların hepsine eee
bakın. Birçoğunuz zaten biliyorsunuzdur
diye düşünüyorum. Şimdi öncelikle
elbette countries, nationalities, flags,
languages, bunlara bakacağız. Bunlar
neler? İşte hangi ülkeler? ülkelerin
bayrakları, milletler gençler, o
ülkelerde konuşulan diller. Öncelikle
sizler de okulunuzda zaten buna
değineceksiniz. Burada dikkat etmeniz
gereken birkaç tane ülke var ve zaten
birçoğunu biliyorsunuz. Aslında ben
sizin dikkatinizi şu şeylere çekmek
istiyorum. Özellikle gençler fl bir
bayrak demek. Bunu bilin. Country ülke
demek. Nationality millet, milliyet ırk
demek. Language ise dil demek. Yani
sizlerin burada aslında bilmeniz gereken
şunlar. Yani ben bu kategorileri biliyor
muyum? Çünkü size şöyle bir şey olacak.
Diyelim yazılıda geldi bir metin geldi.
Metinde birisi konuşuyor, kendini
anlatıyor, arkadaşlarını anlatıyor
vesaire. Ve burada işte I from bla
bla diyor. İşte I can speak bla bla.
Burada işte ı can speak dediğinde sen o
kişinin dilinden hangi dilleri konuşuyor
olduğundan az çok çıkarım yapabilmen
lazım. Ya da ülkesini söylediğinde hangi
nationality yani milletten olduğunu
sizlerin çıkarabilmesi lazım. Yani ben ı
from Türkiye dediğimde sizlerin benim
nationality yani ırkımın I Turkish e
Türk olduğunu, konuştuğum dilin yine
Turkish olduğunu bilmeniz gerekiyor. E
önemli olan yani dikkat etmeniz kısım
burası. Onun dışında zaten ülkeleri
biliyorsunuz değil mi? Türkiye, Turkish,
Turkish. Genelde nationality yani
millet, ırkla dil aynıdır. Birkaç ülke
hariç gençler. Bunlardan birincisi de
zaten the USA, the United States of
America. Amerika Birleşik Devletleri
gençler bunların nationality yani
milliyeti, ırkı American diyoruz biz
gençler. American ama bakın language dil
ise Amerikanca diye bir dil yok. Ne
konuşuyorlar? Tabii onlar da İngilizce
konuşuyorlar. O yüzden onlara da ne
diyoruz? English diyoruz. Konuştuğu dile
English diyoruz. Germany, German,
German. Italy, Italian, Italian. Japan,
Japanese. Japanese. China, Chinese,
Chinese. Canada, Canadian, English and
French. Bakın burada Kanada'da yine
sonradan demek ki bunlar şey olmuş
gençler. Bunlar sonradan kurulan ülkeler
olduğu için tabii hep göçle kurulduğu
için de kendi dilleri yok. Kanada ülke
oradaki millete orada yaşayan insanlara
Canadian diyoruz değil mi? Kanadalı. Ama
konuştuğu dil ise farklı gençler.
English and French. İngilizce ve
Fransızca konuşuyorlarmış diyoruz. Onun
dışında Russia, Russian, Russian,
France, French, French, India, Indian.
Bakın buna da dikkat edin. India,
Hindistan. Hintlilere de ne diyoruz?
Indian diyoruz. Ama konuştukları diller
birkaç tane var. İşte bunlar Hindi, Urdu
ya da English. Bunların hepsini
konuşabiliyorlar. United Kingdom var
gençler. İngiltere'den farklı olarak.
United Kingdom Birleşik Krallık demek.
Yani Galeri de vesaire içine alan
Krallık. United Kingdom diyoruz. Orada
yaşayan insanlara da British diyoruz
gençler. British İngiliz. Konuştukları
dil de İngilizce olduğu için English
diyoruz. Spain, Spanish, Spanish, South
Africa, South African English. Bakın
Güney Afrika'da da resmi dil, konuşulan
dil İngilizceymiş. Bu da yine aklınızda
olsun. Australya, Australian English.
English yine burada da var bakın.
Avustralya eee ülke. Orada yaşayanlara
da Australian diyoruz ama konuştukları
dil yine İngilizce arkadaşlar. O yüzden
de English diyoruz. Bu küçük farklar
aklınızda olsun. Onun dışında zaten
birçoğu aynı gençler. Aynı millet de
aynı yazılıyor, dil de aynı yazılıyor.
Aklınızda olsun. Bu ünitede farklı
farklı birkaç gramer konusu da göreceğiz
gençler. Bunlar önemli konular. Onlardan
bir tanesi de ilki. Hatta subject
pronouns yani özne zamirleri. İsim
yerini bizim kullanacağımız zamirler
gençler. Bunlar neler? Bakın ikiye
bölünmüş. Singler yani tekil olanlar.
Bir de plural yani çoğul olanlar.
Gençler bunlar nedir? İşte bir cümlede
eylemi yapan kişi yani ben yani özne
öznenin yerine kullanacak kişi ya da
nesneyi gösterir ya da cümlede özne
görevinde olan isim veya isim
gruplarının yerine kullanılan
zamirlerdir gençler. Subject pronouns.
Bunlar ı zaten ben demek. You sen. He o
erkekler için ama kullanıyoruz. She
kızlar için o. It ise tabii ki cansız
varlıklar veya hayvanlar için
kullanıyoruz. O bu grup bakın ben, sen,
o yani tekil olanlar. Bir de plural yani
çoğul halleri var. Bunlar da nedir? We,
biz demek gençler. We, biz, you siz
demek. Bakın bu you hiçbir şekilde
farklı yazılmıyor. Tekilde de, çoğulda
da you diye yazılıyor. O yüzden bunu
biraz cümle içerisinde bağlamdan
çıkarmanız lazım. Onun çoğul mu
olduğunu, tekil mi olduğunu. They var
bir de gençler. They de onlar demek.
Bunlar da yine çoğul halleri. Bakın.
Edward bir erkek olduğu için Edward
yerine ben neyi kullanabilirmişim? He'yi
kullanıyorum. Sarah kız olduğu için
she'yi kullanıyorum. A dog bir köpek
diyoruz. Onun yerine it diyebilirim.
Mike and I dediğimde buna dikkat edin
lütfen. Mike ve ben. Bakın ne olduk? İki
kişi olduk. Çoğul olduk. O yüzden
şuradaki ı var diye hemen yazmıyoruz.
Ne diyoruz gençler? Mike and I. Onun
yerine burada we kullanacağız. Biz
oluyor. You and Susan. Sen ve Susan. E
siz ne oldunuz? Bakın siz diyorum zaten.
Sen ve Susan. Siz yani yine you olacak
gençler ama çoğul olan you. Paul and
Lisa. Paul ve Liza yani onlar oluyor bu
da. Onların yerine de dii
kullanabiliyorum. I a student. It is
a book. They are new students. Onlar
yeni öğrenciler diye bakın ne yaptık?
İsimler yerine buradaki zamirleri, kişi
zamirlerini kullanmış olduk. Subject
pronounsları kullanmış olduk. Bakın
burada güzel bir alıştırma var. Parantez
içerisinde özneler var. Biz bu özneler
yerine biraz önceki subject pronounsları
kullanacağız gençler. Bla bla is the
capital of Japan demiş. Şu capital'a da
çok dikkat edin. Bu ünitede özellikle bu
sene eskiden bu capitallardan çok
bahsetmezdi ama artık bu ünitede çok
karşınıza çıkacak. Capital city
arkadaşlar yani başkent. Eee işte Ankara
is the capital city of Türkiye diye
söylüyoruz mesela. E capital başkent
demek aklınızda olsun. E neymiş?
Tokyo'ymuş. Arkadaşlar şimdi ben burada
Tokyo'yu zaten diyelim önceden
kullandım. Tekrar sürekli her şeye Tokyo
yazmayacağım. Onun yerine ne yapıyorum?
Bir subject pronouns kullanacağım. Tokyo
yerine ne kullanabilirim? Tokyo nedir?
Bakın bir cansız bir şeydir, değil mi?
Bir şehir. E şehir yerine ben ne
diyebilirim arkadaşlar? Ne yapıyorduk?
Cansızlar ya da hayvanlar için it
kullanıyorduk. O zaman it is the capital
of Japan diye söylüyorum. İkincisine
baktığımızda bla bla are from Türkiye
demiş. Nokta noktalar. Türkiyeli kim
onlar? Gizem and Gizem ve ben. E biz ne
olduk? Bakın biz diyorum. Gördün mü?
Gizem ve ben. Biz. Biz ne demekti? We
demekti değil mi? We are from Türkiye
diyorum. Bla bla can visit the tower in
Paris. Paris'te EEL kulesini ziyaret
edebilir. Kim edebilir? Bakın. Turist
demiş. Turistler yerine ben ne
diyebilirim? Bakın turistler onlar
diyebilirim. Yani they they can visit
the afel tower in Paris. Bla bla is
Spanish demiş. Spanish. O İspanyol
demiş. Kim İspanyol? Kevin. Ben Kevin
yerine neyi kullanabilirim? Tabii ki
he'yi kullanabilirim. He is Spanish. Bla
bla are at the festival today. Nokta
noktalar bugün festivaldeler. Kimler?
Students. Öğrenciler. Yani yine ne?
Onlar. They are at the festival today.
Lavla is a famous tourist attraction in
Rome. Demiş arkadaşlar. Nokta Nokta.
Roma'daki meşhur ünlü turistik yerdir.
Neresi? The colum. The coloseum nedir
arkadaşlar? Yine bir cansız bir şey.
Yani it olması lazım. It is a famous
tourist attraction in Rome diyoruz. Bla
bla is American. Nokta nokta
Amerikandır. Kim? Rebecca. Rebecca bir
kız olduğu için onun yerine she
diyebilirim. Bla bla can speak Spanish
and English. Nokta nokta İspanyolca ve
İngilizce konuşabiliyor. Kimmiş? You and
Amanda. Sen ve Amenda. Ne oldunuz? Siz
oldunuz, değil mi? Yani yine burada
you'yu kullanmam lazım. Subject
pronounslar bu kadar kolay arkadaşlar.
Zaten yıllardır aslında hep gördüğünüz,
bildiğiniz şeyler. O yüzden çok fazla da
üzerinde durmaya gerek yok. Zaten
ünitenin devamında, sonunda genel bir
alıştırma yapacağız sizlerle quiz
şeklinde. O yüzden umarım sonuna kadar
sıkılmadan izleyebiliyorsunuzdur. Ha bir
de aklıma geldi. Like attınız mı?
Unutmadınız değil mi? Bazen
unutuyorsunuz. Lütfen like atmayı
unutmayın gençler. Şimdi bu ünitede
başka gizli bir konumuz var gençler
bilmeniz gereken. Bu da this, that,
these, those diye. Bunları öncelikle
kısa bir şekilde şöyle bahsetmek
istiyorum. Öncelikle gençler this where
that'e bakacağız. This burada tekil olan
ve yakında olan nesneleri işaret etmek
için, bunlar işaret zamirleri
diyebiliriz. İşaret etmek için
kullanıyoruz. Diz'i bu, that'i de o
olarak çevirebilirsiniz. ikisi de
tekildir. O yüzden is ile kullanılır.
This yakındaysa, that de uzaktaysa
göstereceğimiz zaman that'i
kullanıyoruz. Bunların çoğul hali de
dizin çoğul hali. Burada tabii çoğul
olduğu için arela kullanılır. Yakında ve
çoğul olanlar için kullanacağız dizi
gençler. Bir de does var. Bu da uzakta
ve çoğul alınanlar için de dozu
kullanıyoruz. Çoğul olması lazım. This
ve dozu are'la beraber çoğul
olduklarında çoğullarla kullanıyoruz. E
diz ve that de tekil olduğu için is'le
kullanıyoruz. Bunlar tekili ifade ediyor
gençler. Şimdi burada da doğru olanı
yuvarlak içine alın demiş. Hep beraber
çözebiliriz. Sizler de isterseniz
durdurup benimle beraber çözebilirsiniz.
Şimdi this is these are computer games
demiş. Burada sizin bakmanız gereken şey
bunların devamındaki şu isim. Bu isim
tekil mi çoğul mu buna bakacaksınız.
Çoğulsa arelı olanı, tekilse de izli
olanı kullanacaksınız. E baktığımda
computer games demiş. Bakın s takısı
var. İsmin sonuna S takısı geliyorsa
lerlar çoğul eki oluyordu. Hatırlayın
hemen. Lerlar yani bilgisayar oyunları
diyor. Çoğul olduğu için neyi
kullanacağım o zaman? These are computer
games demem gerekiyor. 2'ye baktığımızda
those are there is a big shopping center
demiş. Bakın a shopping center. Buradaki
şu e'yi biliyorsunuz değil 1 demek. Bir
büyük alışveriş merkezi. E burada 1 tek
oluyor. Tekil olduğu için neyi
kullanacaksın? That is diye
söyleyeceksin gençler. 3'e baktığımızda
these are this is a beautiful novel
demiş. E var bakın yine burada bir güzel
hikaye. Bir güzel roman diyor. E 1
olunca tekil olduğu için yine neyi
kullanacağım? This is demem lazım. 4e
baktığımda there is those are very old
buildings demiş. Bakın yine buildings.
Binalar s takısı var. Demek ki those are
diye söylemem gerekecek. 5'e baktığımda
this is these are funny comics. Bakın
yine s takısı var. O zaman ne diyeceğim?
Bu çoğul olacak hocam. These are demem
gerekecek. Those are that is my ID card.
ID card. Benim kimliğim değil mi?
Kimliğim. Bu benim kimliğim. Kimliğim
bir tanedir zaten. Bir tane olduğu için
neyi kullanıyorum? There is diye
söylüyorum. These are this is palm
trees. Bakın palm trees. S takısı var.
çoğul olmuş palmiye ağaçları diyor. O
zaman these are palm trees diye söylemem
lazım. That is those are a clever
parrot. Zeki bir papağan diyor. O zaman
bakın bir papağan dediği için tek olduğu
için de that is söylemem gerekecek.
Başka bir gramer konusu gençler. Object
pronouns. Az önce biz subject pronouns'u
görmüştük. Hatırladınız değil mi?
Subject pronouns ne demekti? Özne
zamirleriydi. Özne olarak kullanıyorduk.
eylemi yapan kişi olarak söylüyorduk ve
cümlenin başında kullanıyorduk. Object
pronouns'ları ise gençler nesne
zamirleri oluyor. Nesne zamirleri de
cümlede işte nesne görevinde
kullanılırlar ve eylemden bu sefer yapan
değil de eylemden etkilenen kişi veya
nesneleri temsil ediyordu. Eylemi yapan
değil kişi veya eylemden etkilenen
olacak cümlede genelde de o yüzden
fiilin fiilden sonra kullanılıyor. Yani
bizler subject pronounsları I, you, we,
they, he, she, it bunlar vardı ya
bunları cümlenin başında kullanıyorduk.
Object pronouns y nesne zamirlerini ise
genelde fiilden sonra kullanıyoruz
gençler. Aklınızda olsun. Bu nesne
zamirlerini aynı zamanda şurada
edatlarla da kullanabiliyoruz. İşte
with, at, of, about, to, without.
Bunları da işte edatların nesnesi olarak
da yine bu object pronounları
kullanabiliyoruz. Bakın şurada bir
tablomuz var. Subject pronoun dedi. Az
önce söyledik değil mi? Özne
zamirleriydi ve öznenin yerine, eylemi
yapan kişinin ya da nesnenin yerine
kullanabiliyorduk. Bunlar işte ben, sen,
o, biz, siz, onlar. I, you, we, he, she,
it ya da you, they bunlardı. Objectte
ise eylemden etkilenen kişi ya da
nesnelerdi arkadaşlar. Yani burada
diyelim ben cümleyi kurdum. Fiilden
sonra işte ben ya etkilenen kişi yine
ben isem bu sefer demiyorum. Me yani
bana, beni anlamında me'yi kullanıyorum.
You değişmiyor gençler objecte. Yine
sana, seni derken yine you'yu
kullanıyorum. He ne oluyor? Erkekler
için him oluyor gençler. Ona onu derken
him diyorum. She kızlar için o demekti.
Ona onu derken de her diyorum. It cansız
varlıklar ya da hayvanlar için o
demekti. Ona onu derken de yine it
diyorum. We biz demekti. Bize bizi
derken us diye söylemem lazım. You yine
bakın değişmiyor. Aynı şekilde
yazılıyor. Size sizi derken yine you
yazıyorum. They de onlar demekti.
Onlara. Onları derken de them diye
söylüyorum. Şimdi burada hocam ben bunu
nasıl ayırt edeceğim? Yani bu it nesne
zamiri mi? Object zamiri mi? Eee yani
bunu nasıl ayırt edeceğim dersen şöyle
eğer cümlenin başında diyerek it is diye
başlamışsa mesela oradaki it aslında
subject pronoun'dur. Ama daha sonra
fiilden sonra yazılmışsa bu sefer object
pronoun'dur. Siz buna dikkat
edeceksiniz. Bakın şuradaki cümleleri
hemen incelersek zaten anlayacaksınız.
Ne demiş? Can you tell me your phone
number? Bana söyler misin neyi? Telefon
numaranı bana. Telefon numaranı söyler
misin? Kim söyleyecek? Sen. Kime
söyleyeceksin? Bana. Bakın etkilenen
benim. Kim söylüyor? Söyleyen sen. Sen
öznesin burada. Bana ise burada ne
oluyor? Object işte nesne zamiri oluyor.
Buradaki me nesne zamirimiz olmuş
oluyor. Sally gives many presents to
him. Sally ona birçok hediye veriyor.
Hediyeyi veren kim? Sally. Sell bizim
subject pronoun yani özne öznemiz. E
burada object etkilenen kim? Kime
veriyor? Ona veriyor. Bakın him diye.
Buradaki him bizim object pronoun
oluyor. This painting belongs to us. Bu
tablo bize ait. Kime ait? Bize ait. Ait
olan tablo. Bakın this painting bizim
öznemiz. Burada us ise artık nesnemiz
oluyor gençler. Bakın fiilden sonra
zaten bunları kullanıyorum. Bu şekilde
yapabilirsiniz. Şimdi burada object
pronounlarla alakalı güzel bir alıştırma
var. Gelin hep beraber yapalım gençler.
Sizler gerekirse videoyu durdurun,
kendiniz yapın. Daha sonra cevaplarına
da bakabilirsiniz. Boşluğa hangisi
gelecekse onu seçeceğiz. E baktığımda ne
diyor? I love action movies. Ben aksiyon
filmlerini çok seviyorum. Do you love
bla bla. Sen de nokta noktaları seviyor
musun? E neyden bahsediyor? Bakın
aksiyon filmlerinden. O zaman ne
diyeceğim? Sen de onları seviyor musun?
Onları ne demekti? Onları them demekti
gençler. Burada cevabım them olması
lazım. 2'ye baktığımda this is Jack's
passport. Bu Jack'in pasaportu. Give it
to bla bla. Nokta noktaya ver. E onu
kime vereceğim? Jackinse Jack'e ver
diyeceğim değil mi? Yani ona ver. E Jack
bir erkek olduğu için ona derken
erkeklerde neyi kullanıyordum? Him
diyordum gençler. Cevabım burada him
olması lazım. Give it to him diye
söylemem lazım. I have a sister. Benim
bir kız kardeşim var. I often play
tennis with bla bla. Ben sık sık nokta
noktayla tenis oynuyorum. E benim neyim
vardı? Kız kardeşim. Demek ki onunla
tenis oynuyorum. Kız kardeşim yerine
she. E tabii nesne olduğu için de she
yerine neyi kullanıyordum? Her diye
söylemem lazım. 4. We are late for
school. Okula geç kaldık. Bakın kim geç
kalmış? We biz geç kalmışız. My mom
takes bla bla to school. Annem nokta
noktaya okula götürüyor. Kimi götürüyor
okula? Kim geç kalmıştı? Biz. Demek ki
bizi okula götürüyor. Yani burada we
yerine bizi derken uslanmam lazım
gençler. Terry and Olivia are my best
friends. Terry ve Olivia benim en iyi
arkadaşlarım. I really have a great time
with bla bla. Ben gerçekten onlarla
harika zaman geçiyorum. Bakın ne
diyorum? Onlarla yani Terry ve Olivia
yerine onlarla diyorum gençler. Onlarla
da burada them oluyor. Happy birthday
Linda. İyi ki doğdun Linda. This present
is for bla bla. Bu hediye nokta nokta
için bakın. İyi ki doğdun Linda diyorum.
Demek ki Linda benim karşımda. O zaman
ne diyeceğim? Bu hediye senin için.
Senin de ne oluyor? You oluyor gençler.
This present is for you diye söylüyorum.
I can't do my homework. Ev ödevimi
yapamıyorum. Can you help lav'la? Kim
yapamıyor ev ödevini? Bakın. Yani ben
yapamıyorum. O zaman bana yardım eder
misin demem lazım. Yani bana derken de
burada me'yi kullanmam gerekiyor. Umarım
sizler de benimle beraber hepsini doğru
yapmışsınızdır. Ve geldik bu konudaki
başka bir önemli gramer konusuna
gençler. The use of to be in simple
present tense. To be fiili gençler.
Olmak fiilini geniş zamandaki kullanımı.
Olmak fiili. Bu geniş zamanda to be
fiilini biz nerelerde kullanıyoruz? To
be fiili deyince genelde çok bilmeyiz
ama biz bunu genelde emizar olarak
biliriz. Öyle değil mi? to be fiili
çekimlenir çünkü gençler özneye göre
is ya da are olur genelde. O yüzden de
gençler isim ya da durum cümlelerinde to
be fiilini kullanırız. Yani biz emiz
genelde eee fiil olmayan, ana fiil
olmayan yani gelmek, gitmek gibi ana
fiil olmayan genelde bir durumu bildiren
cümlelerde kullanıyoruz. Mesela ben bir
öğretmenim derken burada bakın bir fiil
yok. Olmak fiili var. Öğretmenim
diyorum. Burada işte isı yani to be
fiilini kullanmam gerekiyor. Pozitif
cümlelerde to be fiilini kullanırken
tabii ki ı da am'i kullanıyorsunuz ki
gayet iyi biliyorsunuz bunu. I a
teacher. I a student diyorsunuz değil
mi? Ya he she' de gençler tabii neyi
kullanıyoruz? Is'i kullanıyoruz. We,
you'de de are'ı kullanıyoruz. Burada
ve isilleri ifade eder. Tekil
olduklarını isimlerin are ise çoğul
olduklarını ifade eder. Bu da yine
aklınızda olsun. Örneğin I an artist.
Ben bir romanım. Ben bir sanatçıyım. Ya
da she is 15 years old. O 15 yaşında.
Bakın she olduğu için is gelmiş. We are
at school. Biz okuldayız derken de we
olduğu için are'ı kullandık. Gördüğünüz
gibi burada hiç e mcm alan, mastar eki
alan bir fiilimiz yok. Genelde bunlar
durum cümleleridir. O yüzden de amiz are
yani to be fiilini kullanırız. Gençler
bunlar yıllardır gördüğünüz için çok
öyle detaylı bir şekilde anlatma gereği
de duymuyorum açıkçası. Sadece kısa bir
şekilde değineceğim. negatif form yani
olumsuz hallerine de bakacağız gençler.
Amiz var. Olumsuz halinde de işte not
oluyor gençler. I not. He she de yine
isn't is not ya da isn't kullanıyorum.
We'de de are not ya da aren't kısa bir
şekilde arıyorum. I not a student.
Ben bir öğrenci değilim. Ya da you are
not a teacher. Sen bir öğretmen
değilsin. Burada you aren't diye de
söyleyebiliriz. I not an artist. Ben
bir ressam değilim. She is not 15 years
old. 15 yaşında değil. We are not at
school. Biz okulda değiliz gibi
kullanabiliyorsunuz. Bir de elbette
question form yani soru halleri var
gençler Emar'ın. Soru hallerinde
unutmayın bu sadece bunlar için değil
bütün soru hallerinde yardımcı fiil başa
gelir. Yardımcı fiilimiz neydi? To be
fiili. To be fiil de çekimlenince ne
oluyordu? Zar oluyordu. Yani yine da
am'i başa getiriyoruz. I a teacher?
Ben bir öğretmen miyim? He she' de is'i
başa getiriyoruz. We'de de area
getiriyoruz. Are you a student? Sen bir
öğrenci misin diye soruyorum. Şimdi
tabii ki bu to be fiili başta olunca
gençler yani izar başta olduğunda soru
sorduğumuzda kısa bir şekilde yes no
diye de cevap verebiliyoruz. O yüzden de
ben sana sordum mesela are you a
student? Sen bir öğrenci misin diye
sorduğumda sen işte yes ı evet
öğrenciyim ya da no ı not diye kısa
bir şekilde cevap verebilirsin bana.
Örneğin iscıofya inanbul? Ayasofya
İstanbul'da mı? Yes, it is. Evet,
İstanbul'da. Are you classmates? Siz
sınıf arkadaşı mısınız? Yes, we are.
Evet, sınıf arkadaşıyız ya da no, we
aren't diye kısa bir şekilde cevap
verebiliyorsunuz. Az önce ne dedim? Kısa
bir şekilde yes ya da no diye cevap
verebiliyordunuz gençler. Ama wh
questionlar varsa unutmayın bunlarda biz
yes ya da no diye kısa bir şekilde cevap
veremeyiz. Neden? Çünkü wh questionlar
bizden detay ister. Bu wh questionlar
dediğimiz nedir? İşte what, when, where,
how, which, değil mi? How, often. Bunlar
deta ister bizden. İşte nerede, ne zaman
yani evet ya da hayır diye bunlara cevap
veremeyiz. O yüzden de bunlara istenilen
cevabı vermemiz lazım. Hangi bilgi
istiyorsa bize onu söylememiz lazım.
Mesela what's your job? Mesleğin ne?
İşin ne? I a chemist. Ben bir
kimyagerim. Ya da I a teacher. I a
student diye söyle söylemem lazım. Yani
yes ya da no diye söyleyemem. How are
you? Nasılsın? I fine, thanks.
İyiyim, teşekkür ederim. What's your
name? Adın ne? My name is Daniel ya da
"I Ser" diye kış bir şekilde cevap
verebilirim. How old are you? Kaç
yaşındasın? I 16. I 15. I 20
diye söylüyorum. Who is she? O kim? Who
is she? O kim? She is Martha. My sister.
O Martha. Benim kız kardeşim diye cevap
veriyorum. Gördüğünüz gibi bunlarda yes
ya da no diye cevap veremem. Hangi ne
istiyorsa bizde soruda ne ayrıntı
istiyorsa o detayı vermem gerekiyor. TBI
fiili ile alakalı gel hemen şu
alıştırmayı yapalım hep beraber gençler.
Tekrar hatırlatayım. I da
kullanıyordum. He, she, it ya da tekil
ise bakın tekil bir isim de olabilir.
Tekil ise is kullanıyorum. We, you'd ya
da çoğul ise de arı kullanıyordum. E
buna göre birincisinde diyor ki Tokyo
bla bla the capital city of Japan.
Japonya'nın başkentidir. Tokyo diyor
bakın. Tokyo kaç tane Tokyo var? Bir
tane var, değil mi? O zaman ne
diyeceğim? Tokyo is the capital city of
Japan diye söylemem lazım. My friends e
burada ne olacak? mi olur, is mi
olur, are mı olur? Ne diyorduk biz?
Bakın tekillerde is, çoğullarda are
kullanmam lazım. E burada my friends,
benim arkadaşlarım s takısı var.
Gördünüz mü? Yani çoğul. O zaman ne
diyeceğim? Burası are olacak. My friends
are very happy because yine burada da
they var. Ey'de de ben arı
kullanıyordum. O zaman ne olacak
cevabım? A olması gerekiyor.
German. I'm from Berlin demiş. Hım.
Tamam. Şimdi burada ikisi de pozitif
olacak değil mi? German. Ben Almanım
diyor. I from Berlin. Berlin de
Almanya'da olduğu için evet burası doğru
pozitif olması lazım ama ıda neyi
kullanıyorum? kullanıyorum gençler. E
Berlinliyim derken yine I kullanmam
lazım. Yani iki tarafta olması lazım.
Burada cevabım Ceyhan oluyor. 4e
baktığımda Cambera The Capital City of
Australia demiş. Bakın Cambera yine bir
şehir söylemiş. Şehir tek bir tane olur.
O yüzden burada Cambera is the capital
se of Australia olması lazım. Where var
bakın bir soru cümlesi var burada. The
tourist attractions in Rome demiş.
Burada yine neye dikkat edeceksin? İsme
gençler. İsim tekil mi çoğul mu? Bakın,
"Tourist attractions" diyor. Yani
turistik yerler derken çoğul olmuş. Hani
are kullanmam lazım. Where are the
tourist attractions in Rome? They are.
Burada yine arı arar kullanmam lazım.
6da Republic Day, Cumhuriyet Bayramı.
Cumhuriyet Bayramı bir tanedir. O yüzden
burada is on 29th of October in Türkiye
diye söylüyoruz. 7incisinde de the touch
mahal. Touch mahal. Bir tane touch mahal
var değil mi? O yüzden ne olacak? Yine
is olacak. is in Agra India.
India'dadır. Agra şehrindedir diyor.
What bla bla your nationality demiş.
Senin ırkın nedir? What is your
nationality? I American. Değil mi?
Burada cevabım ne olacak? Bursa olması
lazım. Umarım sizler de bunları doğru
yapmışsınızdır. Son bir konumuz daha var
gençler bu ünitede. Bu da expressing
ability. Yani yeteneklerimizi ifade
etme. Yapabildiğimiz şeylerden bahsetme
ki neyle yapıyorduk bunu biz? can ya da
can't ile yapıyorduk değil mi? Bir şeyi
yapabilme, edebilme anlamında eğer
yapabiliyorsak can, yapamıyorsak da
can'i kullanıyorduk. Bu can aynı şey
gibi zor değil. Emzarda ne yapıyorduk?
Özneye göre çekimliyorduk. İşte ı da
he shete is, we are oluyordu. Can ve
can'tte öyle bir şey yok. Hepsinde aynı.
Hepsinde cani kullanıyoruz. Yani özlem
ne olursa olsun, he, she, it, we, you,
day. Hepsinde can'i kullanıyorum.
yapabiliyorsam yani pozitif bir cümleyse
daha sonra da fiilim artı nesnemi
kullanıyorum. Örneğin I can speak
English, he can speak English, they can
speak English. Onlar İngilizce
konuşabiliyor. Ben İngilizce
konuşabiliyorum diye söylüyorum gençler.
Gayet basit. Ne diyor mesela? You can
visit the castle on Sundays. Kaleyi
pazar günleri ziyaret edebilirsiniz. You
can visit the castle diye söylüyoruz.
Negatif yaparken yani yapamazsın,
edemezsin anlamında da cani kullanıyorum
gençler. I can't speak Japanese. Ben
Japonca konuşamıyorum. Tourist can't
enter the historical site without a
ticket. Turistler bilet olmadan tarihi
alana giremezler. Burada yapamazlar,
edemezler anlamında kenti kullanmam
gerekiyor. Ve son olarak question form
yani soru hali var. Az önce soru halinde
ne yapıyorduk biz? Eizar'ı başa
getiriyorduk. Bu sefer de can'i başa
getirerek soruyoruz. Soruyoruz. Yani
yapabilir misin, edebilir misin
anlamında. Can. Daha sonra yine öznem
neyse burada ı, we, you, they, he, she.
hangisiyse artık. Sonra yine aynı
şekilde fiil ve nesnemi yazıyorum.
Örneğin, "Can you speak Spanish?"
İspanyolca konuşabilir misin? Ya da "Can
she speak Spanish? Can she speak French
diye soruyorsun. Can Kelly go art
museum?" Kelly sanat müzesine gidebilir
mi diye sorabiliyorsun. E diyelim bunu
sordun ya da ben sana sordum. "Can you
speak Spanish diye sordum ya da can you
speak English diye sordum." Sen bana
burada yine can başta olduğu için yes ya
da no diye kısa bir şekilde cevap
verebilirsin. Ne dersin? İşte ben sana
sordum. Can you speak English? Sen de
eğer konuşabiliyorsan yes ı can.
Yapamıyorsan da no diye kısa bir şekilde
cevap verebilirsin. Burada bakın bu can
ve can't'le alakalı güzel bir alıştırma
var. İlk 56 tane alıştırma yapabiliriz
hep beraber. Yukarıda tablomuz var
bakın. Country ülke, capital başkent,
tourist attraction dediği de neydi?
turistik yerlerdi. Yani ziyaret
edilecek, görülebilecek yerlerdi. Burada
da bu tabloya göre what can you do
there? Orada ne yapabilirsin diye
sormuş. Dersin ki mesela Türkiye'de
Ankara'da ne yapabilirsin? I can visit
Atatürk's Moselium. Atatürk mozelisini
ziyaret edebilirim. Yani anıt kabiri
ziyaret edebilirim. Burada Ken'i
kullanacaksın gençler. Anlaştık mı?
Tabii. Burada ne vermiş size bakın. In
Paris demiş. You demiş. You olarak
kullanacaksın. Yani özne you olacak. Ne
yapacaksın? Önce Paris'i bulacaksın. A
da bulduk. Paris'te ne yapabilirsin?
Visit the EEL Tower demiş mesela. Eel
kulesini ziyaret etmek. O zaman ne
diyeceksin? In Paris you can visit the
tower diye söyleyeceksin. In Rome.
Roma'da. Roma'yı nerede? Roma hemen
şurada bulduk. Tourist demiş. Bakın
turistler ne yapabilir? Visit theolum.
Hemen devamında cani ekleyerek can visit
the coliseum. In tourist can see Gong
Bong Kong Palace. Gong Bong Kong Palace.
Bunu nasıl okuyoruz ya bilmiyorum. In
Mexico, we can visit chicken pizza. In
Ankara tourist can visit Atatürk
Muselium diye söyleyebiliriz gençler.
Evet ünitemizin sonuna geldik. Şimdi
tabii hemen kapatmıyoruz. Şöyle
gördüğümüz bilgileri tekrardan bir
güncellememiz lazım gençler. Kısa bir
quiz yapacağız. 100lük puanla kısa bir
quiz. Lütfen sizler de katılın beni
bana. Eee, bakalım şöyle bilgilerimizi
bir ölçelim. Sizler de benimle beraber
çözün. Videoyu durdurun. Kendinizi
çözün. Bakalım kaç alacaksınız. Şimdi
burada soruları cevaplıyoruz. Match the
countries with the flags. Ülkeleri
bayraklarla eşleştir demiş gençler.
Italy. İtalya hangi bayrak? Söyleyin
bakayım hemen. Bravo. Bursa değil mi? Şu
bayrak. France. Şu eydi değil mi?
Edirne. Japan. Hemen şu ortasında nokta
olan cephendi gençler. Denizli olacak.
Mexico şu ortasında bir şeyler var.
Mexico Adana olacak. Canada da yapraklı
olan Canada olmuş oluyor. Bunu kesin
doğru yapmışsınızdır diye düşünüyorum.
Geldik hemen ikinci alıştırmamıza.
Burada da doğru olanı yuvarlak içine
alacaksınız. Emizar yani hangisi
doğruysa o. Rom. Rom ne? Roma. Bir tane
kaç tane Rom olacak? Rom is a city full
of history. Rom tarihle dolu bir
şehirdir. Lucia and Hugo. Bakın. Lucia
and Hugo. Lucia ve Hugo iki kişi
oldular. Çoğul oldular. Are olacak
gençler. Are Spanish. Lucia ve Hugo
İspanyollar. My parents bakın s takısı
var. Benim ailem are on a dream now. I
olacak zaten. Olivia and Dimitri are
olması lazım. Yine and var bakın burada.
or olsaydı olmazdı ama and olunsa iki
kişi oluyor, çoğul oluyor. I the
royal palace is the capital of Russia is
Moscow. They are in Istanbul for eight.
The weather today is. Bugün hava diyor.
Hava da tekil cansız olduğu için is
olması gerekiyor gençler. Hemen burayı
yapalım. Look at the chart and answer
the question demiş. 20 puan gençler.
Tabloya bakın ve cevaplayın demiş. Bakın
bu tarz sorular yazılığınızda da
çıkabilir. Ona göre burada tabloya göre
işte isimler var. Konuştukları ya da
konuşamadıkları diller var.
Konuştuklarına tek konuşmadıklarına
çarpı koymuşlar. Can Haruki speak
Japanese? Haruki Japonca konuşabiliyor
mu? Haruki'ye baktım. Bakın burada
buldum. Geldim Japonca. Evet
konuşabiliyor. O zaman yes he can demem
lazım. Kısa bir şekilde cevap veriyorum.
Can ada speak Spanish? Ada İspanyolca
konuşabiliyor mu? Ada burada. Hop!
İspanyolca konuşamıyor. No, she can't
diye söylemem lazım. Can Martina and
Carlos speak Japanese? Martina ve Carlos
Japonca konuşabiliyor mu? Martina Carlos
bakın buradalar Japonca konuşamıyorlar.
No burada özne olarak bakın Martina and
Carlos dediği için they onlar
diyebilirim gençler. No they can't diye
söylemem lazım. Who can speak Turkish?
Kim Türkçe konuşabilir? Ada değil mi?
Ada can speak Turkish diyorum. Who can't
speak English? Kim İngilizce
konuşamıyor? Baktım bakın bir kişi
konuşamıyor. Carros. Carlos can't speak
English diye söylemem gerekiyor. Çok
kolay. Eminim sizler de Türkçe rez gibi
bunları çözüyorsunuzdur. Hemen bu kısma
bakalım. Son kısım gençler. Burada da
yine sorular var. Cevaplarla
eşleştireceğiz. Birincisi, what's your
nationality? Senin ırkın, milletin ne?
Burada ı Nokta nokta işte ı
turkish, English, I Spanish diye
bir şey söylemesi lazım. Hangisinde bunu
söylüyor gençler? Bakın. I French
demiş. Edirne'de. Yani bir Edirne olması
lazım. What's the capital of Japan?
Japonya'nın başkenti nedir? Neresidir?
Tokyo. Değil mi? Gayet kolay bir soru.
Where are you from? Sen nerelisin? Where
are you? Bakın sana soruyor. Sen de ne
diyeceksin? I. Ben şuralıyım. I from
Spain demiş. Bakın. I from Spain.
Burada Denizli olması lazım. What can
tourist do Rome? Turistler Roma'da ne
yapabilir? Turistler yerine D''yi
kullanırım. Değil mi cevapta? They can
visit the colle. Collezyumu ziyaret
edebilirler. What languages can you
speak? Hangi dilleri konuşabilirsin? I
can speak German and English. Ben
Almanca ve İngilizce konuşabilirim diyor
ve burayı da hallediyoruz. Umarım sizler
de hepsini doğru yapmışsınızdır gençler.
Evet hallettik. Buraya kadardı gençler.
Ünte anlatımız. Umarım sonuna kadar
sizler de gelebilmişsinizdir. Umarım
beni buraya kadar izleyebilmişsinizdir
gençler. 1. üniteyi böylelikle
hallettik. Aklınızda herhangi bir soru,
bir istek varsa elbette aşağıda
yorumlara yazabilirsiniz. Gözüm
yorumlarınızda olacak. Ayrıca unutmayın
yazılı videolarınızı da şimdiden
hazırlamaya başlayacağım. Yakında yazılı
videolarınız da gelecek. Tabii ikinci
ünitenizde gelecek gençler. Umarım çok
güzel bir seneyi hep beraber geçiririz.
Hepinize tekrardan başarılar diliyorum.
Sizleri çok seviyorum. Bir sonraki
videoda görüşünceye dek kendinize çok
çok iyi bakın. Hoşça kalın.